[Musique]
le geste est précis et efficace pour
Mariana Mateos préparer les ormeaux
semblent un exercice facile la truffe
des mères comme on la surnomme est à
l'honneur ce soir-là chez mommento
je me fais plaisir mais je le fais que
certaines tomes parce que ce n'est pas
accessible à tout le monde et ça ça
c'est un produit nécessairement c'est
normalement de mois d'octobre à décembre
je crois donc c'est c'est très relation
elle est très très courte mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas donné donc je propose
ça détendre
je suis parti de Mexico quand j'avais
16-17 ans
j'ai atterri à Angers pour faire pour
apprendre les Français car je peux
parler papa en seulement de français
j'avais toujours eu envie d'être chef
j'aime beaucoup manger dans ma maison de
manger des très très belles choses donc
j'ai suivi en France avec les buts
d'être admis dans son école des
gastronomie en France pour moi la France
est le pays où la gastronomie de plus
d'effort dans le monde entier donc voilà
après j'étais admis sur l'Institut de
Paul Bocuse où j'ai passé 300 puis trois
ans et demi chez Hélène Darroze avant de
rejoindre Frédéric ducat à l'instant
d'Or à Paris juste le temps d'obtenir
une étoile et elle part chez Racine New
York avec son mari enfin en mars 2019
Mariana Matéos et Thomas Jacquet décide
d'ouvrir leur restaurant momento à buée
juste avant les premiers confinements
pour moi c'était très important de
m'exprimer je m'exprime à travers ma
cuisine et pour pour moi venir à mon
métaux c'est comme si vous venez
vraiment chez moi dans ma maison et pour
moi les buts c'est que vous passez un
excellent moment
[Musique]
influencé par son parcours entre le
Mexique et la France Mariana prend le
meilleur des deux avec audace et panache
les pigeons c'est un produit que
j'utilise aussi exceptionnellement pour
préparer une recette qui me tient
vraiment à coeur c'est la tourte des
pigeons foie gras champignons et choux
c'est tout le reste que j'ai appris à
faire avec mon chef et mon menteur
Frédéric doukart donc il m'a pris à
faire ça et du coup je le fais à son
honneur dans mon restaurant
mais je pense que c'est important entre
cuisiniers de transmettre
les gestes les bas c'est surtout le
travail l'heure que c'est la cuisine
Mariana Matteo ça le regard tourné vers
les étoiles sans jamais oublier de faire
pétiller les papilles des visiteurs de
passage demain pour le dernier épisode
de cette série rendez-vous au Lancelot
chez Catherine de lacoutte pour une
nouvelle rencontre